[Música]
Rusia bombardea masivamente Ucrania las
fuerzas de Moscú lanzaron 81 misiles
contra kievs saporiyad ni progerson old
entre otras ciudades el kremlin defiende
que se trató de ataques de precisión
como respuesta a la explosión en el
puente de crimea se cuentan hasta el
momento 11 muertos y decenas de civiles
heridos
la tormenta Julia avanza por
Centroamérica en Honduras el fenómeno
causó al menos tres muertes después de
haber devastado parte de Nicaragua de
las Islas colombianas de San Andrés y
Providencia y de Panamá donde se reportó
otro fallecido conectaremos con nuestro
corresponsal en Guatemala donde ya llegó
la tormenta
recibieron el Nobel de economía 2022
según la academia sueca los premiados
ayudaron a comprender el papel de los
bancos en la economía de Mercado
particularmente durante las crisis
financieras
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania
porque Rusia escaló su ofensiva sobre
Ucrania en horas de la mañana de Europa
las fuerzas de Moscú bombardearon
masivamente el territorio ucraniano de
norte a sur y de este a oeste el
ejército ruso disparó 81 misiles sobre
kiev VIP hardkif saporiya jerson y
mikolaif entre otras ciudades el kremlin
habla de un ataque de precisión sin
embargo se cuentan al menos 11 muertos y
decenas de heridos civiles recordemos
que los bombardeos se producen tras la
explosión el sábado en el único puente
que une al territorio ruso con la
Península de crimea hanneccionada por
Moscú en 2014 este lunes el presidente
Putin acusó a Ucrania de cometer ataques
terroristas kiev no ha asumido la
autoría de los hechos sin embargo el
mismo sábado el presidente ucraniano fue
lo dimirselensky celebró la explosión de
forma metafórica hablando de una jornada
muy soleada en Ucrania y con nubes sobre
crimea ahora para analizar este giro en
la ofensiva rusa Contamos con Carlos
Pereira director del equipo de dossier
geopolítico y analista de seguridad
Carlos buenos días Rusia habla de
represalia con ataques de precisión sin
embargo vemos ataques contra zonas
residenciales y civiles porque recurre
Putin a este tipo de ofensivas es una
muestra de su poderío o por el contrario
de debilidad en estos momentos de avance
de los ucranianos en el frente de
batalla
mire estamos en presencia de una guerra
ya
totalmente definida y totalmente lanzada
esto es más que claro Entonces estamos
en presencia de algo que parecía que no
se tomó en cuenta las recientes
declaraciones de Putin que no iba a
aceptar ningún ataque terrorista en su
territorio especialmente en las zonas
fronterizas con la es república
ucraniana Y creo que esta respuesta ha
sorprendido absolutamente a todos aún a
los que gestaron este atentado sobre el
puente que une Ucrania Perdón que une
Rusia con este la Península de crimea
esto es una Clara demostración de que la
guerra se ha profundizar y de que a
partir de ahora es lo que dijo Putin
hace un par de meses
esta guerra recién empieza y estos son
evidentemente los resultados de este
bombardeo que se realizó esta madrugada
entonces usted comenta que considera que
este ataque masivo este bombardeo que se
ha producido hoy es una respuesta de la
explosión en el puente de crimea no se
trata entonces de un cambio en la
estrategia decidido previamente se
retrata de una respuesta a lo sucedido
del sábado no estamos ante un regreso a
la guerra Total como al principio de la
ofensiva y por otro lado se han esfumado
ya las posibilidades de diálogo
vamos por parte lo primero es que
estamos en presencia de una gigantesca
guerra híbrida global que ya no
solamente involucra a la federación rusa
y en su momento a la República ucraniana
sino como todos sabemos que esto es un
enfrentamiento y le dicen todos los
analistas que es un enfrentamiento otan
que encabeza Estados Unidos de
Norteamérica y la federación rusa y
detrás de la federación rusa un sector
de los países llamados potencias
emergentes como es Rusia India China
etcétera
y por otro lado rápidamente contempla
usted la posibilidad de que Rusia llegue
a usar armas nucleares como han
advertido tanto biden como Celeste
yo creo que eso es una es un relato que
ha lanzado algunos poderes de occidente
el mismo Pentágono ha desmentido la
declaraciones de vaiden diciendo de que
no tienen ningún dato de que hayan
movilización de tipo de armamento
nuclear ruso hacia la fronteras con
Ucrania por lo tanto forma parte de un
relato propagandístico de guerra que no
podemos asumir los analistas en serio
cuando vemos este conflicto que ya se
podría ver solucionado hace varios años
atrás y de que no se ha logrado Porque
alguien alguien impidió que se
alcanzaran y se lograrán el cumplimiento
de los dos acuerdos de paz que se firmó
en el 2014-2015 bien Carlos Pereira
Muchísimas gracias por su tiempo y por
su análisis gracias a ustedes
continuamos con más información
relacionada con el bombardeo de hoy
porque la comunidad internacional
condenó enseguida estos a nuevos ataques
rusos contra Ucrania el secretario
general de la otan jeans calificó los
bombardeos de horribles e
indiscriminados y la comisión europea
habló de crímenes de guerra
estoy conmocionada y horrorizada por el
feroz ataque contra kiev y otras
ciudades ucranianas Rusia una vez más le
ha mostrado al mundo lo que representa
este error y brutalidad los responsables
deben rendir cuentas estamos de luto por
las víctimas y envié mis más sinceras
condolencias a nuestros amigos
ucranianos sé que los ucranianos no se
dejarán intimidar y los ucranianos saben
que estamos a su lado todo el tiempo que
sea necesario
en los términos más enérgicos los
ataques deliberados de Rusia en todo el
territorio ucraniano y contra civiles lo
que supone un cambio profundo en la
naturaleza de esta guerra
cambiamos ahora de información vamos con
temas de nuestra región la tormenta
tropical Julia avanza por Centroamérica
el fenómeno causó al menos tres muertes
en Honduras después de haber devastado
parte de Nicaragua de las Islas
colombianas de San Andrés y Providencia
y de Panamá donde también se reportó que
una persona falleció sepultada por
escombros conectamos ahora con nuestro
corresponsal en Centroamérica Andrés
Suárez Jaramillo Andrés Buenos días la
tormenta Julia tienen alerta roja a
países como El Salvador o Honduras y
acaba de llegar a Guatemala Donde usted
se encuentra que se espera del paso de
este fenómeno climático
rosa muy buen día aquí en Guatemala las
lluvias no han cesado Desde la madrugada
De este lunes territorio guatemalteco
donde ya ingresó la tormenta Julia
degradada como depresión tropical de
acuerdo con el Centro Nacional de
Huracanes de los Estados Unidos sin
embargo Aunque este fenómeno
metereológico sus vientos ya hayan
descendido a 56 kilómetros por hora el
nivel de precipitaciones preocupa porque
ya hay decenas de municipios
incomunicados deslaves Ríos inundados
Por lo cual fue activado el protocolo de
evacuaciones están canceladas las clases
y el sistema de atención a desastres
está pendiente de lo que pueda llegar a
ocurrir este lunes en cuanto al Salvador
de donde proviene la tormenta por la
costa del Pacífico la Policía Nacional
de este país ha anunciado la muerte de
dos personas en un municipio del oriente
luego del derrumbe de varios muros y al
parecer una tercera estaría también
sepultada Honduras por su parte que es
un país centroamericano por donde no
atravesó la tormenta directamente ha
sido ha resultado uno de los más
afectados
riadas intensas desbordamientos de ríos
provocaron el ahogamiento de tres
personas centenares de familias
afectadas y Se presume además Fuentes
extraoficiales dicen que una embarcación
de siete personas estaría desaparecida
vaya Andrés y por otro lado Julia golpeó
a Nicaragua como huracán de categoría
uno antes de degradarse como usted decía
atormentada Tropical Cuál es el balance
en ese país
en Nicaragua la información que se
obtiene es muy reducida sin embargo de
acuerdo con la vicepresidenta Rosario
Murillo quien funge como la directora de
comunicaciones del país no hubo saldo de
víctimas mortales Eso sí más de 1.500
familias afectadas 70 Ríos desbordados
3000 casas destruidas y 300 árboles
caídos Lo que sí es que el norte y el
sur del Caribe nicaragüense se encuentra
todavía completamente incomunicado dado
que se dañó el tendido eléctrico y la
red de telefonía y se espera a lo largo
del día que se obtengan noticias de este
sitio bluefields por donde ingresó Julia
convertida como huracán de categoría 1
Andrés Muchas gracias por el reporte
vemos a la lluvia de trashuyo cuídese
mucho
nosotros cambiamos de información vamos
a Europa este lunes comenzó en París el
juicio por el siniestro del vuelo de la
compañía francesa Air France que se
accidentó en 2019 mientras cubría la
ruta entre Río de Janeiro y París
228 personas murieron en el accidente
por lo que la aerolínea francesa junto
con El fabricante airbus enfrentan un
proceso judicial inédito en Francia bajo
la acusación de homicidio involuntario
ambas firmas se declararon inocentes nos
lo explica a Juan pupiales
una justicia que llega 13 años tarde era
la Consigna de este hombre padre de una
de las 228 fallecidas del vuelo af447
perdimos a nuestra hija y su prometido
ambos de 29 años
un gran sufrimiento por parte de ambas
familias pero el tiempo cura la herida
sin embargo todavía sentimos que aún no
se ha hecho justicia
para los familiares de las víctimas ya
es un logro haber llegado hasta esa
instancia Y es que hubo que revertir una
decisión judicial de 2019 para abrir
este proceso contra Air France y airbus
dos firmas insignias de Francia las
cajas negras y evidenciaron que los
pilotos reaccionaron de manera
equivocada a un problema relacionado con
los sistemas antihielo en las salas y
que provocó una situación de bloqueo de
la aeronave el resultado una caída libre
contra el Océano Atlántico en medio de
una tormenta el France asegura que una
serie de alarmas confusas abrumaron a
los pilotos herbas dice que fue un error
de los pilotos muchos interrogantes en
torno a un equipo que sumaba más de
20.000 horas de vuelo juntos este lunes
ambas empresas reiteraron su inocencia
vine hoy a expresar el nombre de Air
France nuestra más profunda compasión
con los familiares de las víctimas
dije lo que tenía que decir intenté ser
tan sincero como fue posible en relación
con lo que ocurrió
unos 50 ha llegados de las víctimas
hicieron parte de la apertura de este
juicio Habrá más de 470 testimonios hoy
uno a uno se leyeron los nombres de los
228 fallecidos se espera que el juicio
se extienda por nueve semanas y cada
compañía se enfrenta a una multa de
225.000 euros el equivalente a lo que
Air France ganaba en cinco minutos en
tiempos pruebandémicos o lo que hervas
sumaba en ganancias en dos minutos
y en otras noticias hoy se otorgó el
premio Nobel de economía Abel barnan que
Douglas Diamond y phillip divic por
Investigar los bancos y las crisis
financieras según la academia sueca de
las ciencias los premiados contribuyeron
significativamente a la comprensión del
papel de los bancos en la economía
particularmente durante las crisis
financieras lo que ha ayudado a regular
los mercados y hacer frente a las crisis
bernanki quien presidió la reserva
Federal de Estados Unidos durante la
crisis del 2008 analizó la gran
depresión de los años 30 considerada la
peor crisis económica de la historia
moderna además demostró que los bancos
fueron un factor decisivo para que la
crisis se hiciera tan profunda y
prolongada en cuanto a Diamond
desarrollaron modelos teóricos que
explican Por qué existen los bancos como
su papel en la sociedad los hace
vulnerables a rumores sobre su colapso y
como la sociedad se puede limitar esta
vulnerabilidad
de ciencias ha decidido hoy otorgarle
premios 2022 en ciencias económicas en
memoria de Alfred Nobel Avengers
institution Washington DC Estados Unidos
Universidad de Chicago Estados Unidos
de la Universidad de Washington en San
Luis Estados Unidos obtuvieron el premio
por la investigación sobre bancos y
crisis financieras
for resorts on Banks and financiera
crisis
Muchísimas gracias por su atención ya
saben pueden ampliar toda esta y más
información en France 24 en nuestra web
France 24.com Y por supuesto en nuestras
redes sociales sigan con nosotros que
enseguida volvemos
[Música]